pleased to have back here on the rich
eisen show the grammy and emmy
award-winning
multi-instrumentalist releasing his new
album alone with my faith available on
march 19th harry connick jr how are you
doing harry
what's happening rich how you been
i've been great man you know getting
through this
pandemic staying safe and
keeping my fingers crossed that
everybody makes it through to the other
side yeah i'm knocking on wood right
here for all that me so the album
that we're talking about you created
during lockdown
in your home so is that is that a true
story i did yeah so we were on tour last
year and
like everybody else everything just got
canceled so i came home
and i should note that i was one of the
fortunate ones who got to spend
that time at home and uh i was thinking
i'd like to to do an
album maybe you know now i always wanted
to do was a gospel album
and and i started recording some tunes
by myself i played all the instruments
and set up all the mics and
and as as the weeks passed i started
thinking about
my faith and to be quite honest with you
i'm catholic but but i was thinking you
know my faith is really strong right now
or some days i was
you know standing on shaky ground a
little bit and so i wrote about all of
that stuff and
and as i talked to people over the
course of the weeks and months i found
that
a lot of people were going through the
same thing so the album is
is some spiritual that everybody knows
like the old rugged cross
and how great they are but it's also got
a lot of other songs
um that that are based on how i was
feeling at the time
yeah and and you know we're gonna be
hearing quite a bit about
um you know a one-year anniversary this
this week
um it was one year ago this week and
throughout the week
where lockdowns began uh across the
united
states where we where where i guess
coast to coast
a lot of people began to realize just
the seriousness of this situation
and um so how long did it take for you
to
soak in what was happening and say let
me now turn to
music to try and and put this all down
so i can
commemorate and memorialize all of this
harry well before the first couple weeks
i i'm sure you remember how you felt i
mean we i don't know what the heck was
going on i mean i didn't know
i mean we didn't know anything i mean we
were you know indexing every
grocery bag and you know shoes and
for the longest time because we just
didn't know um and for the first couple
weeks
i filmed this youtube show from my
basement called hunker down with harry
basically
you know to give people some maybe some
diversion or some respite from what was
going on but it was
a lot for me too because i felt like i
was able to
share my feelings with everyone but
after that you know
couple of weeks i said let me let me
record some music about this because i
i have i've never recorded in real time
what i was feeling
like if you go through a breakup or
somebody in your family is
sick or dies the last thing i want to do
is go make music about it
because i'm dealing with the the grief
and the in the loss but this was
different because
everybody was going through the same
thing i was by myself
i had all of these instruments around me
and i said let me let me try to
articulate musically what i'm feeling
and and that's what i ended up doing
and uh did you pick up a new instrument
or just all stuff that you knew
already had to well the the the newest
instrument that i
have is called the harp edgy it's
actually pretty cool if you your
listeners want to look it up it's
called h a r p e j j i and this guy in
baltimore
makes it with his wife and children and
it's kind of like uh
it's like a wooden slab with strings on
the top and you kind of hammer the
strings but
it's not like any other instrument like
a dulcimer or something it's like it's
kinda like a piano kinda like a guitar
so i've had that for a year that's my
most recent uh instrument but i played
you know
on the record i played trumpet and
saxophone and bass drums and
do all the vocals the hardest part which
was being the recording engineer because
that's
that's not my skill set so you know
miking all the instruments
uh was a little treacherous for a while
but but i figured it out
well harry you know uh i know we hadn't
spoken in a while but you know my house
is your house
i have an audio executive here uh that's
how he wants to be known
he's a sound engineer he's mike del tufo
uh he's from new jersey he
he very rarely makes a mistake and when
he does he does claim to say my bad
could you have helped harry on this sort
of he could have helped him okay mixed
bands i used to mix on the tonight show
he could have helped
richard
i gotta be honest with you um i've never
heard of the heart peggy before so i
don't know how i'd be able to mix
a harpage to be honest with you did i
even pronounce it
you got it as we say new orleans you
play like you live man you just
figure it out you know
harry connick jr here on the rich eisen
show all right let's get into it um can
you give me any insight as to whether
drew brees is going to continue to play
football with the new orleans saints
because we're all expecting him to um
move on to his next act which we're all
sure is going to be his greatest is last
what do you think
harry what do you know anything i mean i
i know drew i've known him for a while
but i would never ask him that just
because i don't know makes me
uncomfortable like even during the
season i would never text him it just
freaks me out
but i mean i i mean i hate to see him go
i mean but i think he could probably
play another year
all of the stuff he was dealing with
besides his ribs this year
makes me think that he could have thrown
the ball a lot farther down the field
like
apparently his foot was jacked up and he
had a shoulder injury so
i don't know man i mean if he comes back
i'm all for it but i'm also a huge
taysom hill fan
like i've said that to people in the
business and like come on man
he's not a starting quarterback but i
really think he is i just think
you know give him some time in the
preseason let him play
i love taysom hill man everybody gets
excited when he goes in so
whatever whatever happens you know it's
it'll be for the best i'm sure
coach payton knows knows what to do i
guess here on this show we're covering
all our
uh our new orleans celebrity bases we
had the actor anthony mackie here he
loves jameis he wants jameis
he thinks that james could push the ball
down i love james winston two minutes
arm is so ridiculous but
man i i think the potential for
interceptions is so
high but like when he came in on that
one play and threw it like 60 yards down
the field
i mean that's awesome but i i think our
screen game is so important
i i don't know i i wouldn't want to tell
james winston to his face that i'd
rather see
he'll start but i'd rather see some
he'll start
so who was your saint growing up uh
harry who was that guy when you were
growing up
watching the saints well i liked all a
bunch i mean obviously i like archie but
i like people i like elo grooms and like
danny abramowicz and all people like
that i love ricky jackson
um sam mills i love that whole era um
but when you know the snake was in there
i loved him i mean i have there's so
many
i was i even had one of aaron brooks's
shoes in my house so
you know i'm a okay now i got a hard fan
no i have to stop you there harry what
do you
what do you mean by the way did you did
you play the aaron brook shoe on your
on your new album i mean because i don't
know i mean what do you mean
yeah track four on amazing grace that
that is
that's the shoe i'm flicking off the dry
dirt off the cleats and
it sounds just like a tambourine what do
you mean you have an an aaron brooks
shoe in your house just one singular
aaron brook shirt
i have like a bunch of memorabilia i
have michael thomas
signed the jersey to me the first year i
got all kinds of stuff like that
and i don't know how i ended up with it
but i i actually have
uh one of them you know as i say at rich
i
[Laughter]
it shows your fandom harry it really
does you know
um if you're just i'm a big saints fan
no if you just come into it surf into it
you know you
you know you might counsel the brooks
family to get a restraining order but
you know it is it it just shows off your
it shows up
it shows well now if you're gonna start
i actually stole it from his house while
he was home
now if you're going to say you got a
bobby a bear sock then that's the end of
this conversation you know what i mean
now now we're going to love that you
know that to go with the shoe
that would be that's the that's the the
holy grail oh
my gosh you know then then then we gotta
then we gotta talk about uh the future
here but no
in all honesty though it just shows off
your your your fandom
is your do you have a similar love for
the pelicans now and zion or
is hoops not really your game or yeah i
love them but
obviously the history is not there like
with saints but yes i love the pelicans
but you i don't know if you know this
but i had a i had a a
tv show called harry show a couple years
back and one of the things we did was to
go down
to new orleans and they mickey loomis
actually signed me for a day
so i was a saint for a day and what you
do but i was petrified because of the
prospect of
being traded can you imagine
like doing like a celebrity signing and
they trade you
well i mean that would be a different i
don't know what would be the equivalent
to to come back in a trade harry i mean
they can't get value yeah i mean you'd
have to you know
get your manager involved calling other
teams you know save face
but they did actually sign me to a
one-day contract and i know this sounds
crazy
maybe not i mean you guys are the best
people talk to about this yes
my heart exploded because those guys are
they're like they're gods i mean what
musician would not love to be an athlete
and since i have no athletic skills at
all just to be down there like to be
on the field and and and watch those
guys
in in just a stupid you know phony
ceremony of signing that contract was
it was like worth more to me than you
know any award i've ever won
you know for anything else it was a
dream come true
harry if you're ever in that situation
again harry connick jr here let me help
you out here because
i can safely uh attest to the fact that
yes
you're a musician strolling onto a field
of world-class
professional athletes and you're like
okay every musician wants to be an
athlete
but the reverse is true every athlete
wants to be a musician i've heard that
uh that's it um
oh the center for the for the um
for tech uh the basketball center david
robinson yes he he came and sat in and
played basically one day
i was so i get it how was you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of mutual
admiration
well i mean you know there's there's a
ton of uh
of players football basketball who think
that they can
they can rap that they hate that they
have the ability to be some sort of a
star i mean shaquille o'neal
we all know has been attempting to do
that sort of thing
uh le'veon bell i know that yeah
i mean you know those those guys are so
creative what they do i
i love it it's just it's just and it's
fun to see them
you know whenever an athlete comes to
one of our shows
i think the last one who came was kurt
warner and it's just the whole band
freaks out like we just
we can't get enough of that stuff as
those those guys are
you know they're heroes to us and when
they you know the
the great people that we we think they
are it's it's it's like drew
like like he's just a fantastic guy
and and you know it just it's inspiring
it's it to know that he goes out there
and does that
um you know i mean we go out on stage
you know we don't
have the the physical dangers that they
have and it's just amazing i mean
they're gladiators and
we just we're so thankful for for
that type of entertainment before i let
you go harry connick jr again his new
album alone with my faith available on
march 19th that's just right around the
corner
give me a good story from uh
independence day do you have one how you
got involved with anything
else great story they called and said
hey we want you to be in this movie
it's going to be a giant blockbuster
with will smith and i said okay cool you
know
send me the script so they sent me the
script and i die on like the sixth page
like seriously that's
what you want me to do and then i find
out yes man we sure are glad you're here
because
glad you're here because we asked
matthew perry to do the part but he
couldn't do it i'm like
okay so i'm your second choice and i
died
on like you know the eighth page so
there's a story
so i did not know matthew perry was in
line for
playing captain jimmy wilder may he rest
in peace spoiler alert
from what i understand he was the guy
and i kind of
i came in and uh you know
did my thing yeah by the way we had
chris morton
gave it all i had we had chris mortensen
of espn on before and he
heard that you were coming on uh he and
his uh was he say it was his wife
watch it watched copycat last night and
wanted me to pass along to you
about how dynamic and uh you were in
that role
in that film harry that was that was um
you know what's crazy about that
i was 22 23 years old they said look
they want you to meet this director
i met this guy named john emile he's
from england we sat down and talked for
a minute he says what do you know about
serial killers i said
not much i know you know what i read in
the papers he says can you do a really
really strong southern accent i said
yeah i said i know you're from england
but i kind of have one now but
i can i can jack it up and and do some
other
uh some other accents whatever
reason you want to talk about and then i
walked out and i'm like well
you know i'm not going to get that and
then then he called my agent said yeah i
want him to i want her to play this part
i'm thinking what
what did i reveal to this guy in this
half an hour that would
make him think i could play this this
this guy
so i never never really asked him that
because i didn't want to know but
it was that was a fun role to play too
well i had to sleep on the couch for a
month after i did that movie
well i hate to tell you harry um uh we
we know david schwimmer was the first
choice for that role um
just an unusual sort of playing against
type kind of part
i don't know that was just sitting right
there for me to say i'm sorry i just
stopped
having my fun um yeah and uh you know i
set them up you knock them down that's
my job i guess hey harry uh thanks for
joining me
on the show anytime i would love to have
you if you're
just want to talk some ball just want to
get on if you have an album to promote
or whatever i'd love to just uh continue
a conversation so i appreciate the call
and congrats on the album in advance
chris i'm a big fan i have been for a
long time and uh y'all stay safe
we will do that thank you so much alone
with my faith
harry connick jr he played all the
instruments
he mixed everything together he said
mike deltufo could
have helped him he is obviously a great
human
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here